Podcast Wunderschönen guten Tag, hallo und herzlich willkommen. Ich will gar nicht, dass das Intro aufhört hier vom lieben Ferdinand. Da sind ja ganz neue Töne, Florentin Will. Ich will ehrlich gesagt gar nicht, dass wir anfangen und das Intro aufhört. Aber gut, dann muss es jetzt wohl anfangen mit Stefan Tüze
und Florentin
Will. Dankeschön,
das war Ferdinand, einer dieser
jungen aufstrebenden Künstler und
Musiker, die ihren Intros
Franz Ferdinand? Nein, es ist nur Ferdinand.
Ich weiß nicht, ob die sich getrennt haben, einer von beiden
macht noch weiter, und ein wahrer
Künstler merkt man daran, dass sie ihren
Intro einen Titel geben. Das mag ich immer gerne.
Und ein Wave-Datei ist und keine MP3 mehr.
Absolut, ja. Da merkt man schon immer, okay, das ist nicht einfach Intro acht, abgeschicken, jetzt abschicken, final, ach doch nicht abschicken, sondern der Name des Intros lautet Zündung. Und das passt ja gut, denn ich würde sagen, wir sind on fire, weil wir angezündet wurden. Da hat jemand gezündet, er hat ihn mit Streichhölzern nicht liegen lassen können. Und deswegen vielen, vielen Dank, Feldenand, dass du uns hier ein bisschen Feuer unter dem Podex machst. Vielen Dank auch von mir und eine schöne Ausgabe wünsche ich uns allen. Es geht ja wieder los. Viel Spaß. Viel Spaß, es geht ja wieder los mitUfo. Und es ist ja viel passiert. Eine Runde noch. Ja, es ist so viel passiert. Es ist ja eine Woche hinter uns, es ist so viel passiert. Ich weiß gar nicht, wo ich anfangen soll. Ich weiß nicht, wo man soll. Sollen wir alphabetisch durchgehen oder chronologisch? Okay, nee, alphabetisch finde ich gut. Wir fangen an mit Aalwoche. Die Aalwoche. An der Ostsee ist Aalwoche. Und haben wir gedacht, dass alle Aale weggehen? Nach ein paar Tagen waren alle Aale weg. Hätte ich auch nicht gedacht. Ich dachte, wie immer, wieder viel zu viel gekauft. Und am Ende war es dann doch wieder alles weg. Aal am Spieß, Aalcreme, Aal Risotto, Aal Knoten, esse ich auch immer gern. Du nimmst ein Aal aus. Weißt du, welchen Satz ich eigentlich liebe, den man sehr oft sagt? Ich brauche dich. Nee, das müsste man eigentlich mal häufiger machen. Das ist ein Satz, den ich sehr mag. Weil ich dachte gerade bei Aal, den sollte man, also eigentlich sollte man mehr von denen verzehren, mehr von denen töten, mehr von denen töten und mehr von denen aufessen. Ich finde nur mehr von denen töten. Ah, okay, ja, finde ich auch gut. Es ist ja nicht so schwer, du machst einfach einen Knoten rein, dann können die nicht mehr richtig schwimmen und gehen langsam unter. Und dann finden die auch nichts mehr zu fressen. Und da sind wir in einem U-Boot mit einem grossen Regenschirm, aber umgedreht und dann fangen wir die auf unten. Wie so ein Minispiel, wo wir immer zur richtigen Stelle schwimmen müssen. Und wenn wir Power-Ups sammeln, so Algen oder so, können wir für einen kurzen Zeitraum schneller schwimmen oder sowas. Und dann gucken wir mal, wer den höheren Highscore hat. Das Game könnt ihr jetzt bei Steam wishlisten, es heißt Aalfang, Aalabfang, Aale abfang, Gedankenstrich, das Podcast-Ufospiel, da könnt ihr jetzt das wishlisten bei Steam. Und ihr findet uns bei der Gamescom in der Indie-Booth. Ja, schaut mal gerne rein in die Indie-Booth im dritten Stock. Wir sind unterm Dach, ist ein bisschen luftig da oben, aber kommt gerne mal vorbei. Ab und zu werfen wir Aale runter. Die könnt ihr fangen, dann kriegt ihr ein Präsent, Socken. Ja, und die Socken sehen aus wie ein langer Aal. Du hast vorne, bei den Zehen hast du den Aalkopf und dann geht der ganze Aalkörper, die Socken gehen auch wirklich bis zum Oberschenkel. Ja, es sind Knieschrümpfe. Es sind Knieschrümpfe, die gehen komplett hoch für einen langen Aal. Strapse.
Nee, weißt du das Wort?
Knieschrümpfe.
Ich weiß nicht, ob Strapse, die werden noch oben festgemacht.
Ja, fach den Legens.
Die werden an den Schultern noch mal befestigt.
Ja.
Und dann noch mal einmal komplett mit Hosenträgern rübergezogen.
Sehr gut.
Ja, das hätten wir das.
Das ist wirklich etwas, was mir gerade am Herzen liegt.
Ich bin nämlich wirklich an der Ostsee.
Ich bin jetzt für eine Woche, werde ich an die Ostsee fahren, sogar ein bisschen länger, zum Schreiben. Und es ist ein bisschen lustig, weil das ist ja eigentlich so ein Altersding. Also Martin Sutter zum Beispiel fährt immer an die Ostsee, ist in so einer Krassen, in so einem Hotel und trinkt Champagne und hat so eine Writer-Suite und so und muss aufs Meer gucken, um auf eine Idee zu kommen. Habe ich immer für Bullshit gehalten, jetzt mache ich es einfach mal selber. Aber ist auch viel Stress, oder? Exakt, das kenne ich mir auch. Wenn man dann denkt, okay, heute habe ich nichts geschrieben, dafür bin ich ja da. Genau, man fährt an die Ostsee, irgendwie baut man mehr Druck auf als nötig, weil ich fahre an die Ostsee, um keinen Druck zu haben, um da in Ruhe schreiben zu können, um mal nicht abgelenkt zu werden von Alltagskram, aber dann fährt man da hin und jetzt bildet sich so eine Nervosität, weil ich denke, ah, es läuft wie so ein Taxometer, weil man bucht ja auch einen Urlaub, man bucht sich eine Unterkunft, heisst, man hat eh schon so einen Preis drauf und ich stelle mir so vor, man kommt dann da hin und dann drückt jemand so auf den Taxometer und dann läuft so
die Uhr runter und man denkt sich, ich habe noch nichts geschrieben.
Und du kennst ja deine Gage. Du weißt ja,
dass du fünf Seiten schreiben musst, um
den Tag wieder reinzuholen finanziell,
den der Urlaub gekostet hat. Das heißt,
wenn du nur drei Seiten schreibst, bist du minus.
Meine Angst ist eher, dass du zu
viel von der Ostsee in deinen Skript
dann fliessen lässt, dass du dich zu sehr
Das passt gar nicht rein. Das passt überhaupt nicht rein. Überhaupt nicht rein. So, du schreibst ja so ein bisschen über die RAF und dann auch irgendwie was da so auch intern ist und auch die Anfänger und alles. Und ich hab halt Angst, dass du da ständig irgendwie, ah, wollen wir noch mal ein Aalbrötchen essen oder in die Sauna oder lass uns mal am Wattenmeer gehen und sagst, wir sind mitten in Berlin. Und dann sagt du, nee, aber dann lass uns extra mal ans Wattenmeer fahren, weil das ist ja auch herrlich und so. Und dann diese Shots von dem
Grau in Grauen Wattenmeer und all das. Genau, also das ist
wissen viele nicht, aber nach Glocken in Dublin
ging es jetzt dann auch darum, in
und mein Rom-Teil, der hieß ja
Tauben in Venedig? Schatten in Rom?
Schatten in Rom, Glocken in Dublin
geht es jetzt um einen Film,
der ist jetzt ganz anders, der spielt nicht
in dieser Trilogie, in dieser heiligen Trilogie,
sondern die ist vollendet
und fertig und perfekt,
die wird nicht mehr angefasst, aber jetzt wollte der
Verleih und der Verlag wieder
so einen reißerischen Titel, das ist halt
mein RHF, ein bisschen ein biografisches Werk, ein Drehbuch, was ich jetzt schreiben werde, und ja genau, es heißt Waffen in der Hose. Ah, okay, alles klar. Die Waffe in der Hose. Und es geht aber eigentlich um ja, RHF-Attentate, aber genau. Okay, es ist kein R-A-L-F oder so, das wird noch nicht
mehr geändert je nach Film.
Dann doch, weil an der Ostsee ist halt dann wirklich
in Havrug ist Aalwoche und ich werde
mal vorbeischauen. Es gibt ja auch diesen
Film über J.K. Rowling.
Rowling.
Und wo man,
und das ist so ein ganz absurder Film,
weil man sieht so ihr Leben, wie
Harry Potter veröffentlicht wurde. Man kennt ja die Geschichte, dass sie ganz oft abgelehnt wurde und keinen Verlag sie haben wollten. Dann die Initialien. Die Essenfrösche, die sich bewegen. Raus hier! Das ginge gar nicht. Der überlebt einen Avada Kedabra, wer soll das denn glauben? Raus hier! Und als Zuschauer denkt man, okay, das steht jetzt nicht so. Wenn es der gleiche Typ war, der zum einen nicht glaubt, dass man sich bewegende Frösche isst, aber dann auch so sehr in der Welt ist, dass er Abrakadabra so glaubt als Fluch und dann aber nicht glaubt, dass jemand das überlebt, finde ich fantastisch. Und das Absurde an dem Film ist, dass man halt diesen kreativen Prozess eines Buchschreibens, der oft ja relativ profan ist, dass man den ja als Film irgendwie erklären muss, so wie kommt jemand auf seine Ideen, was ja, wie du weißt, einfach in Masturbation und Fieberträumen oft einfach mündet und dann schreibt man sich was auf in der hastigen Sprachnachricht. Und da hat man aber dazu sich entschieden, diese Geschichte mit dem Buch, dem ersten Harry Potter Buch, dann ist sie in einem Zug unterwegs und dann kommt jemand mit so einem Wagen rein und verkauft Süßigkeiten und so. Und sie denkt sich, Hogwarts! Schnell, ich muss das niederschreiben! Hogwarts, ach ja, der kleine Kobold, der die Kleidung braucht, um frei zu sein. Und das macht den Film so ein bisschen absurd. Und so stelle ich mir das auch so ein bisschen bei dir vor, dass wenn man
den Film kennt und dann du erzählst,
wie du den Urlaub verbracht hast, dass man
genau alles merkt. Ah, der goldene Schlüssel.
Ah ja, ich verstehe schon. Ah ja, der
goldene Schlüssel unterm Bett und wo dann
irgendwie Uwe Lehnhardt
da dann
irgendwie die Waffen gefunden hat und die Hanggranaten
da in dem Verschlag unter dem
Boden und so, dass man das dann alles rekonstruieren kann. Und dann ist aber trotzdem so nautische Dinge, schleichen sich so an. Ja, die ganze Zeit. Überall liegen Seesterne auf offener Straße. Seesternregen. Ja. Welche Filme hast du geguckt, während du da im Hotel warst? Der Seesternregen. Der Seesternregen, plötzlich, aus dem Nichts. Aus dem Nichts, ja, weiß nicht, finde ich ganz cool. Ja, ich finde, ich bin
da zweierlei Meinung, zum einen freue ich mich
sehr, auch weil ich alleine
in den Urlaub fahre, macht man ja selten,
finde ich irgendwie wahnsinnig schön,
mag ich sehr, das so ein bisschen zu genießen,
zu sich zu finden, ein bisschen durchzuatmen,
mag ich alles,
dann finde ich es ein bisschen angsteinflössend, weil halt dann
doch viel Druck drauf ist, weil man halt so ein Projekt
Urlaub um was, wenn das Projekt nicht schaffbar ist in der Zeit oder, keine Ahnung, nach zwei Tagen fertig ist.
Das ist die Horrorvorstellung, das ist die absolute Horrorvorstellung.
Aber hattest du nicht, hast du uns nicht lange am Haken gehalten mit deinem Segelschein?
Segelschein hier, Segelschein da, das haben wir monatelang mitbekommen und hören müssen.
Jetzt reist du ans Meer.
Gibt es denn die Möglichkeit, dass du da mal so einen alten Kutter beschwingst und dich da mal in die Wogen wirfst? Vielen Dank an der Stelle übrigens nochmal an Fishing King, die mir eine ganze Angel geschickt haben, geschenkt haben, haben die mir einfach zugeschickt. Vielen Dank. Einfach so? Ja, als ich ihr erzählt habe, dass ich einen Angelschein mache. Haben die mir einfach so, ohne dass sie eine Gegenleistung wollten oder sowas, ein Set geschickt, weil ich erzählt habe, dass ich einen Angelschein machen möchte. Ja. Jetzt ist es erstmal vertagt. Es ist erstmal vertagt. Also das ist übrigens auch leid an Fishing King. Das müssten die aber auch besser wissen, dass wenn Stefan irgendwas erzählt von der Phase, die Porto-Zeit, die Versandzeit reicht schon nicht aus, um noch die Phase zu treffen. Wenn Stefan sagt, ich bin jetzt Bonsai-Fan und ihr schickt in dem Moment einen Bonsai-Baum los, kommt der nicht mehr in der Bonsai-Phase an. So schnell lebe ich es mittlerweile beim Titel. Also entweder Expressversand oder Last Design. Das ist jetzt ein bisschen erinnern zu sagen, ich werde den wahrscheinlich noch machen irgendwann,
vielleicht, vielleicht auch nicht, also vielleicht
haben wir da noch gegenseitig was von.
Es sei nur gesagt, wenn
ihr aus dem Bereich
kommt, grob, aus der Ecke,
in der ich irgendwie eine neue Phase
propagiere,
die sich anbahnt oder sowas,
haut auf den Expressversand.
Aber nimmst du die Angel mit? Also hast du vor, da musst du sagen, gar nicht.
Nein, darf man ja nicht.
Darf man ja nicht.
Ja, aber wer hat, wem gehört denn das Meer?
Gar nicht mehr.
Sorry, wer ist denn der Herr des Meers?
Wer gibt denn da die Vorstellung? Poseidon?
Neptun.
Ja gut, und dann ziehst du den Zorn des Neptun auf dich. Und dann?
Moment, Moment.
Was soll er machen? Du fährst zurück nach Kölle?
Poseidon und Neptun. Das ist das Gleiche, ja, griechisch und römisch. Griechisch und römisch sind wir jetzt gelandet. Meine Frage ist immer, was ist was? Ja, ja, aber das musst du zumindest schon mal wissen. Poseidon ist griechisch, ne? Ja, ja. Ja, weil da kam es... Die Basics hast du doch drauf anscheinend. Ja, es klappt doch, es klappt doch, Mensch. Das mehr gehört Poseidon oder Neptun. Die Frage ist, wer der gerade zuständig ist. Das ist ja wie das rechte und linke Nasenloch. Eins ist immer zu, es haben nicht immer beide gleichzeitig Dienst. Der wer dann aufs Maul hält, der eine ist wie so das nette Elternteil, der findest du ja okay, wenn du da der Angel da mal reinhältst. Good God, bad God. Ja, good God, bad God. Hast du immer die Kombination. Der andere ist sehr schlecht, ein schlechter Gott und sagt dann, nee, das kann sie, weiß ich nicht, ob das hier reinhalten darf oder nicht. Aber ich mag die Vorstellung, also ich finde das schön, egal was ihr jetzt die folgende Woche macht, ich weiß ja nicht, was ihr so macht, ihr geht vielleicht auf die Go-Kart-Bahn oder ihr helft bei einem Umzug oder ihr, ihr findet eine Leiter im Wald und denkt euch, wo führt hin? Und ihr klettert die Leiter hoch und sie führt immer höher und immer höher über die Wolken und über die Baumdecke hinauf. Und ihr denkt euch, Moment mal, jetzt ist schon nach sieben. Und dann werden die Sprossen zu so grossen Blättern, die aber so wenig so trittbrettmäßig, dann kann man so hochklettern. Und ihr denkt euch aber, ach scheiße, jetzt kletter ich schon zwei Stunden lang hier hoch, ich brauch mindestens zwei Stunden runter, dann ist es dunkel, ich kletter lieber noch mal runter, jetzt ohne zu wissen, was oben ist. Also ab irgendeinem Punkt muss man sich ja, ich sag ja nur, ab irgendeinem Punkt muss man sich entscheiden, will ich noch weiter klettern oder wieder runter? Boah, ich hoffe, dass du niemals in deinem Leben einen Film schreibst oder irgendwas, wo Leute Zeit investieren und dann endlich geht's los und dann, ah nee, ah, jetzt muss ich dann doch wieder, ah nee, aber jetzt
muss ich runter. Ich will Filme sehen, wo Leute realistisch
und nachvollziehbar handeln, wo man sagt,
dann guck eine Doku. Der Sonnenuntergang
ist in anderthalb Stunden, ich bin schon zwei Stunden geklettert,
ich sollte jetzt umdrehen, nicht, dass ich mich
vertrete und dann irgendwie mehrere Kilometer in meinen
Tod stürze. Dann guck eine Doku, da
handeln nämlich Menschen immer nachvollziehbar und
logisch, wie der Mann mit tausend Kindern, alles nachvollziehbar und logisch. Keine Fragezeichen.
Wir wissen nicht, was ihr macht. Ich bin gerade aufgewacht, ich bin kurz eingeschlafen. Wir wissen nicht, was ihr die folgende Woche macht, aber ihr könnt jederzeit, egal was ihr macht, daran denken, dass Stefan Tietze, ich stelle mir vor, mit so einem kleinen Block, mit so einem Grafit-Bleistift sitzt er da auf so einer Klippe, um ihn herum brandet, das Meer Gischt spritzt, hoch Salz in der Luft. Herr Thieze, kommen Sie da weg, kommen Sie da weg! Und du, nein, und du schreibst so Interior VW Polo Berlin und schreibst es da so schnell. Die Waffe, legt er auf den Beifahrersitz. Sollte ich sie mitnehmen oder nicht?
Und dann steckte er sie doch in seine Hose.
Etwas unbequem, aber das war jetzt sein Leben.
Cut to zwei Wochen früher.
Ach, lame.
Stefan, lame.
Aber das mag ich an deinen Filmen, dass sie den Zuschauer fordern.
Das ist ja oft so, man startet mit der Actionsequenz, um den schon mal aufzuwzuwachen. Hallo, hallo, hallo, irgendwie wird durchlöchert mit 13 Kugeln und du weißt gar nicht, wer ist das, sondern zack, acht Monate früher und dann siehst du Toast aus dem Toaster. Und dann so, die Comedy-Gag immer so, ah nee, Spaß, drei Wochen später, ah nee, zu früh weiter zu früh nach vorne gespult. Das mag ich, dass du das nicht machst. Du fängst direkt mit dem Toaster an. Toast schießt aus dem Toaster. Da wo andere Credits hätten, da fange ich jetzt an. Da fällt mir übrigens ein, vor zwei Wochen hast du einfach die schlechte falsche Meinung, also einfach die falsche Meinung geäußert. Ich habe nicht getäuscht. Das ist sich vertan. Du hast gesagt, es gibt keine guten Prequels. Prequels sind inhärent schlecht, allein weil sie so sind, wie sie sind, also qua natura sind sie schlecht. Und jetzt ist dir nach zwei Wochen ein Prequel eingefallen, was gut ist? Nicht mir, nicht mir. Mir hat ein Werther Hörer geschrieben bei Instagram, und zwar hat er gesagt, was für eine Bullshit-Diskussion, Florentin hat doch einfach den Verstand verloren. Es gibt doch eine Serie, nämlich, hier habe ich gefunden, Matthias schreibt, kurze Prequel-Sache, ein Beispiel, wie es gut funktioniert, ist doch Better Call Saul. Toll, als Prequel von Breaking Bad, da spielt das Prequel ja regelrecht damit, dass man den Blick in die Zukunft hat und sich fragt, warum beispielsweise Kim nie in Breaking Bad auftaucht, nicht wenige mich angeschlossen sehen diese Serie sogar als besser als Breaking Bad an. Also er bringt da sogar Meinung rein, ein bisschen viel finde ich, obwohl man sogar weiss, dass Saul nicht sterben kann etc. Und da hat er recht, tolles Profilbild auch, also wirklich alles stimmt. Kann niemand sehen gerade, kann niemand sehen, aber nur ganz kurz, ich möchte mich da ein bisschen erklären, was ich damit meinte. Ich meinte nicht, dass Prequels schlecht sind, ich meinte nur, dass die gängige Kritik an Prequels oft ist, ja der Charakter ist ja ganz anders. Also du siehst Galadriel jetzt in Rings of Power und sagst, ja so ist ja Galadriel nicht in den Filmen, so kenne ich sie ja nicht, das ist nicht meine Galadriel, aber natürlich muss ja der Prequel-Autor überlegen, wie kann sich eine Figur verändern, dass sie am Ende so ist wie die Figur, die wir kennen. Deswegen sagen viele Leute, ja, so ist ja Solo gar nicht, so ist ja Galadriel gar nicht, so sind die ja gar nicht. Das heißt, ich finde das ja nicht, es ist nicht meine Meinung, dass Prequets schlecht ist, nur das ist eine gängige Kritik, dass man sagt, das würde ja eine XY gar nicht tun, aber sie muss sich ja anders verhalten. Mir ist es so einfach, es ist so Save the Cat-Gelaber, der Charakter muss am Ende ganz woanders sein, als er am Anfang war, ich find's bullshit, allein das ist ja schon Quatsch und ist ja eine Kunstantithese. Wir warten alle auf dein RAF-Drama, wo du eine neue Ära beginnen kannst und neue Regeln schreibst und du sagst Fuck the Cat. Ja, das ist doch alternate history. Man denkt, wo fahren sie hin, hä, war da nicht der Anschlag irgendwo? Nee, die fahren an die Ostsee. Die fahren an die Ostsee und nehmen ihre Waffen und schmeißen sie in die Ostsee rein, das ist die erste Szene und dann Poseidon hat die dann und die schlummern da auf dem Boden und du siehst nur so, wie die Waffe so ganz nach unten auf dem Meeresboden geht und dann die Waffe landet so unten in einem Close-Up und du siehst nur, dass von der Seite so eine Hand kommt, zack, cut, sofort weg, Toaster aus... Und den Dreizack hat man kurz gesehen,
zack, cut, zwei Wochen früher.
Toast schnellt aus dem Toaster,
Uwe Böhnhardt, ich heisse leider
keinen einzigen Namen der fucking RAF,
ich denke die ganze Zeit, was
Urike Bader, Werner
Meinhoff, sowas,
neben dem Toast legt ihn der Tochter
vor die Nase auf den Teller.
Wen haben wir hier, wen haben wir hier, wir haben zum Beispiel
nur um einen zu nennen, Friederike Krabbe.
So, wir haben Ingebot
Vielen Dank. Neben dem Toast legt ihn der Tochter vor die Nase auf den Teller. Wen haben wir hier? Wen haben wir hier? Wir haben zum Beispiel, nur um einen zu nennen, Friederike Krabbe. So. So, wir haben Ingeborg Barz, Angela Luther, wir haben Ingrid Siebmann, wir haben Friederike Krabbe. Krabbe, super, sehr gut. Hauptfigur, perfekt, passt perfekt zur Ostsee. Friederike Krabbe, die in der Ostsee will. Nice. Und immer wenn sie das sagt, dass die Krabbe heilt, guckt sie in die Kamera und zwinkert. Ja. Sching, sching. Gut, der schreibt sich doch von ganz alleine. Am Ende wird es ein Kampf zwischen RAF-Terroristen und Poseidon und der Armee, der Meer, des Meerheers. Ja, die Aale. Der Herr des Meeres gegen RAF. Ja. RAF. Und das ist dann der große Showdown. Sehen wir den ganz am Anfang denn schon? Uwe Böhnhardt, Ulrike Meinhof wird von einem Dreizack erstochen. Zack, vier Wochen früher. Ja, zack, vier Wochen früher. Toast, schnell aus dem Toaster, alles ist ruhig, Frühstück und sagt, unter kapitalistischen Bedingungen kann ich nicht länger leben, nein Ulrike, ja Ulrike, nein Ulrike, das schreibst du jetzt. Bla bla bla, Dialog, Dialog, Glog, Techniker, Techniker, du jetzt Zeit, das alles auszuformulieren mit deinem ganzen Witz. Was mich immer genervt hat, was das Schlimmste am RAF finde, ist, wie, dass es immer RAF ausgesprochen wird. Ich kann das nicht mehr hören. Würdest du es aussprechen? RAF. Statt? RAF. RAF. Also, gesprochen E-R-R-A- E-F-F. Aber das könnte doch die erste Szene sein. Sag mal, kannst du mal aufhören, wie heißt Hessen RAF, nicht RAF? Hä, ist doch kein Risch. Wir sagen RAF. Nein, wir sagen RAF, nicht RR. RAF. Wir sagen RR. Du, ich bin kurz davor auszusteigen. Acht Wochen später. Acht Wochen vorher. Wie soll man es nennen? RAF, sehr gut. Acht Wochen später. Siehst du, damals hast du gesagt, das ist eine gute Idee. Ja, damals. Gut, dass wir das jetzt gesehen haben. Ich wusste ja nicht, dass du das gesprochen hast. Finde ich ideal. Es braucht mehr Crossover. So, wir haben leider einfach nur acht Ideen in unserer Kultur, die sind jetzt auserzählt.
Wir haben nur Jurassic Park,
Die Schlümpfe, Paddington Bear,
Star Wars, Avengers,
It,
Horror It,
Dumbo. Wir sind noch im Gruseltober.
Dumbo.
Kleiner künstlerischer Einwurf.
Das ist ein kleiner künstlerischer Einwurf. Es fehlt nicht an Crossofern. Danke. Und warum die nicht einfach mischen? Ja, Paddington und Schlümpfe zusammen. Geil, hab ich Bock drauf. Guckst du so ein Paddington-Schwachsinn? Paddington ist erstens kein Schwachsinn, sondern wunderbar herzliche Literatur und Filmkunst des Herzens. Der hat ja immer einen Regenmantel an, was als Bär ja absolut verständlich ist, weil das Letzte, was du als Bär willst ... Man sagt ja, du riechst wie nasser Bär. Richtig, du willst nicht nass werden als Bär. An dieser Stelle möchte ich einen Filmtipp äußern, weil ein Nischen, so ein ganz kleiner Nischenregisseur, Schindlers Liste, ja, wir wissen es jede Woche. Francis Ford Coppola hat einen neuen Film ins Kino gebracht, Megalopolis, war ich im Kino. Absurde Erfahrung, eine absurde Erfahrung, also wirklich ein Film, guckt euch den im Kino an, wäre mein Tipp, einfach, also der ist nicht gut, gar nicht gut, sogar herausragend schlecht, aber das macht ihn fast wieder zu einem Erlebnis, was man gerne mal erleben will. Hast du dir ein Eis geholt? Kein Eis. Kein Eis. Ist du Eis im Kino oder ist das gar nicht? Ich war rawdogging im Kino. Completely rawdogged. Ja gut, du hast einen Film gesehen. Ist das dann wirklich rawdogging? Ich war, ich sag's dir, Alter, ich war rawdogged im Kino. Hast du mich grad Digger genannt? Alter, Dude, ich war gerade, ich war, ich hab gerowardockt im Kino, Boy, Boy.
Ja, beeindruckend, krass, ich fand Eis ist das Schlechteste, was du im Kino essen kannst, es wird ja immer verkauft am Anfang, bitte warten Sie jetzt, jetzt wird noch Eis verkauft und so, und ich weiß nicht, warum man das soll, Eis, da kommt ja dann nochmal das Licht an und so, jetzt können Sie sich nochmal Eis kaufen und ich weiß nicht warum, dass ich da d zu sich gesetzt habe, das ist das schlechteste. Ich schling mein Eis in drei Sekunden runter, ich will ja was langes haben beim Film. Und du schlingst auch dein Popcorn in drei Sekunden runter und deine Nachos sind auch dann schon weg. Das stimmt. Generell die Snacks haben wir schon mal, finde ich nicht so geil im deutschen Kino, ist alles ein bisschen lame. Naja, wir sind ja auch mal zusammen, die wenigen Male, wo wir zusammen was gemacht haben, sind wir zusammen ins Kino gegangen mit einem weiteren befreundeten Schauspieler von dir.
Und dem habe ich die Weintrauben gewaschen.
Damian.
Ja.
Das Damian die Weintrauben gewaschen.
Da würden, also sehr viele Mädchen würden dafür töten, Damian die Weintrauben, keinen Euphemismus zu waschen.
Ja.
Aber ich habe es, das schreibe ich auch in jedem Lebenslauf.
Ich habe Damian die Weintrauben gewaschen und der hat einfach eine Packung Weintrauben völlig selbstverständlich
mit ins Kino genommen. Damien schmuggelt auch immer
Sushi und so mit ins Kino,
weil er nach dem Gym wahrscheinlich keine Zeit hat.
Oh Gott, du hast so
coole, tolle Freunde,
die so viel machen und es ist wirklich
ein Traum und es ist wirklich herrlich.
So, das war A mit Aal.
B, der große Briochebrand. Habt ihr das mitbekommen? Hunderttausend Tonnen Brioche. Hunderttausend Tonnen Brioche sind abgebrannt. Würdest du von dir behaupten, du machst gute Brioche? Nein, ich mache wirklich Gott ein Brioche. Also wirklich, Finger weg von meinem Brioche. Sollte ich euch jemals ... Sie stehen dann doch in meinem Büro. Sie stehen doch in meinem Büro, aber ich würde sagen, Finger weg, nehmt niemals von mir Brioche-Geschenke an. Ich mach gern Brioche, aber es ist sehr aufwendig. Man muss eine Stunde lang kneten. Muss man da rumkneten. Es ist ärgerlich, wenn so viel Brioche jetzt einfach den Flammen zum Opfer fällt. Die hätten so viel Gutes machen können, aber leider in Südfrankreich ein riesiges Feuer. Hat man gesehen aus Köln tatsächlich. Viel Hefe, Hefe-Kulturen gestorben. Sehr viele Hefe-Kulturen. Der Hefe-Genozid. Und komplett Frankreich hat drei Tage lang herrlich gerochen, muss man sagen. Es hat herrlich gerochen, aber es war auch ein Denkmal an die unfassbaren Mengen, die da zerstört wurden. Schade. Wir sagen C'est la vie. Wir sagen Daumen runter. Genau, das Podcast-Uto gibt einen Daumen runter. Kommen wir jetzt also zu Buchstaben C. Was passiert die Woche, Stefan? In Chemnitz gab es eine Eröffnung von etwas, was man nicht gedacht hätte. Der erste Urban Outfit hat es in Chemnitz aufgemacht. Und da sagen wir Thumbs Up. Zwei Thumbs Up. Toi, toi, toi. Nach Chemnitz. Drei von vier Shoppingtüten gibt es von Podcast-Ufo-Team. Die Redaktion hat nämlich ... Zwei Daumen nach oben und drei von fünf Shoppingtüten. Drei von vier Shoppingtüten. Vier Shoppingtüten, okay. Finden wir gut. Finden wir richtig gut. War jetzt auch lange in den Themen, weil Chemnitz hat sich ja lange gesträubt gegen Urban Outfit, das hat gesagt, keine Ketten nach Chemnitz, das war ja so lange KKK. Ja, keine Ketten nach Chemnitz. Da hat sich ja auch eine Gruppe gebildet, die da relativ vehement war. Die hatten ja in Chemnitz kein Starbucks, kein McDonald's, kein Burger King, kein O-Blätter, kein Five Guys, kein Lindschokolade. Gar nicht. Nur lokale Manufakturen, Backwerk, nichts dergleichen. Wie lebt man da? Das war das Besondere in Chemnitz für mich so ein bisschen. Keine Kette in Chemnitz. Und jetzt gibt es tatsächlich den Urban Outfit als erste Kette in Chemnitz. Glückwunsch, sagen wir und stattet euch aus. Urban ist ohnehin unser Modestil, würde ich sagen. Also wir sind eher urban als ländlich allgemein, deswegen sagen wir top, top, top. D für Dino-News. Es gibt wieder Dino-News, Dinosaurier könnten so geklungen haben, schreibt uns Chris Beer in unserem Reddit. Kommt im Reddit vorbei, 13.292 Mitglieder. Da kriegt ihr die News noch bevor sie im Podcast sind. Also falls ihr nicht immer zur Podcast-Veröffentlichung warten möchtet, dann holt euch da gerne die frischen News ab, da sind sie noch heiß. Also, man hat wieder herausgefunden, wie die News auch geklungen haben könnten. Hier hören wir ein... Wildlife Sanctuary in Western Australia, and I thought they had a lion. That's a bird. Das ist ein Vogel an. Vogel dreht sich um. Do it. Do it! Do it! Oh, Alter, das ist das Beste. Das ist ein Vogel, der... Was ist das für ein Vogel? Und man denkt wirklich, holy shit,
ist das das schlimmste Raubtier der Welt?
Oder und oder das
It-Monster, Horror, Gruseltorber,
Sternchen, kommt gleich darauf zurück.
Die Vögel,
gerne. Nee, aber dann tatsächlich
ist es ein Vogel. Und wir denken,
oh nein, das klingt wie fucking Vögel,
wie lame sind Dinosaurier. Nein,
vielleicht nicht. Generell muss ich sagen,
finde ich Vögel auch recht furchterregend.
Ich finde auch Emus furchterregend,
Und für die ach nein, das klingt wie fucking Vögel, wie lame sind Dinosaurier. Nein, vielleicht nicht. Generell muss ich sagen, finde ich Vögel auch recht furchterregend. Ich finde auch Emus furchterregend, Vogelsträuse furchterregend. Ich finde, die haben durchaus das Potenzial, gefährliche Apex Predators zu sein. Von daher müssen wir uns vielleicht von unserem Vogelbegriff entfernen, im Sinne von Federkleid, Piepmatz. Ich will den Ausdruck Piepmatz will ich nicht mehr hören. Mauser, Mauser. Nein, weg damit. In die Schublade der aussortierten Begriffe, das sind üble Tötungsmonster. Ich war letztens bei einer Flugshow mit Habicht, Adler, krassen Sachen, da hast du dann so einen Lederhandschuh und dann werfen die immer so Beutetiere, so eine Maus in die Luft. Die Maus denkt sich die letzten drei Sekunden ihres Lebens doch, wuuuuh, da kommt so ein fucking Adler mit wirklich 200 kmh Sturzflug, batz, haut den weg. Was war der coolste Adler? Der Adler war cool. Was war der coolste Adler? Es war ein Adler, ich weiß nicht mehr genau, wie der Adler heißt, Höhenadler oder was auch immer. Es war ein Adler. Also du gehst da so live mit den Jungs hin und die sind eher wegen diesem Saufen da und euch interessiert dann nicht so richtig, wie ihr dann
heisst. Warum ist man bei einer Flugshow und weiss
dann noch nicht, wie der Adler hieß? Wenn die Flugshow sagt,
wir haben ein Habicht, einen Falken
und einen Adler, frage ich nicht, ja, aber was
für ein Adler? Dann wäre doch meine Frage,
was für ein fucking Adler? Da waren nur Achtjährige.
Glaubst du, ich stelle eine Frage
oder was? Ja! Glaubst du,
die ganzen Kinder sitzen da und ich so, ähm, Entschuldigung, also eine Frage hätte ich dann doch noch. Was für ein Adler ist das denn genau? Als ob das so eine fucking Snobfrage ist, wie der Scheißvogel. Du stellst doch keine Frage bei einer Vogelshow, bist du bescheuert? Bist du komplett neben der Spur? Hast du alle Federn verloren, du Lackaffe, oder was? Aber man muss doch, erstens ist das doch für Fragen, ist doch eine Wigtaufklärung. Nein, es gab nie den Punkt während der Show, dass jemand gesagt hat, hat jemand Fragen, gab es nicht. Erstmal finden wir erstmal gut, dass diese Fragen nicht kommen. Ich finde nur Fragen stellen, ich liebe neugierige Menschen, ich habe ein großes Verständnis von neugierigen Menschen und ich finde es nicht, Entschuldigung, Sir. Aber du bist dann auch so jemand, wenn jemand eine Frage stellt, dann drehst du dich so um, um die Person zu sehen. Nein, nein, nein, ich weiß genau, was du meinst. Ich hasse diese Menschen. Genau, der bist du. Gereckter Hals, Stielaugen, wer spricht da hinten? Ja, aber nur, weil ich wissen will, ob das Bild, was ich mir vorstelle, zu dem Menschen passt, der spricht.
Nee, aber ich habe neulich eine Führung gemacht.
Ich war ja mit Freunden in Italien.
Und da haben wir eine
Führung eines Weinguts gemacht.
Und wir waren tatsächlich nur wir drei.
Es waren nur wir drei.
Und das hat irgendwie
20 Plätze, irgendwie maximal.
Und nach uns die Tour hatte auch 20 Leute.
Wir, irgendwie nicht, wurde niemand dazu gebucht oder so, einfach nur zu dritt gewesen.
Und da dachte ich mir, das ist ja meine Stunde.
Also bei 20 Leuten habe ich gar nicht den Mut, eine Frage zu stellen.
Bin ich viel zu ängstlich und schüchtern.
Aber bei diesen drei Leuten, und zwei davon kenne ich gut,
da habe ich wirklich alle Fragen gestellt, die mir eingefallen sind. Was war eine Frage zum Beispiel, also was kannst du jetzt hier mitbringen als Anwissen? Boah, das war so viel. Das war so viele Fragen. Für den Weinguten, da kannst du ja viel fragen, also wie viele Weintrauben. Wie alt die Reben sind, war eine Frage. Und wie alt sind die? Unterschiedlich alt.
Dann war eine Frage, was sind so, welche Rebsorten hat man in so einem Chianti?
Unterschiedliche. Ganz viele unterschiedliche, aber 90 Prozent mindestens Sangiovese.
Und so, dann wollte ich natürlich wissen, weil jeder Jahrgang schon Tücken hat, sei es durch Bakterien oder tückische Bakterien oder jetzt war es ja feucht, das ist die Frage, dann, also wann, wann, wisst ihr, wann geerntet wird und dann messen die den Zucker und beim richtigen Zuckergehalt kommt es raus und so und dann wollen die natürlich schon irgendwie immer den gleichen Geschmack. Ja, na klar. Das ist bei, sagen wir mal, Weinen, die nur aus einer Rebsorte bestehen, oft dann irgendwie noch beste, erste Lage und irgendwie so sich selber ein bisschen schwieriger machen, voll schwierig, weil du kannst das ja nicht mischen. Beim Chianti musst du mindestens 90 Prozent Sangiovese haben. Dann wollte ich wissen, wie bleibt dir eurer Linie treu, ohne den Wein allzu sehr zu verändern. Man kann ja auch Wasser reinkippen, aber das ist ja nicht geil. Da kannst du auch einfach ein bisschen Cabri-Sonne reinkippen, ne? Also ich meine, am Ende des Tages. Eben, dann ist aber kein Chianti mehr. Du kannst nicht mehr als Chianti verkaufen, dann verlierst du deinen DOCG-Siegel. Meine Frage ist, warum schmeckt ... Aber es hat alle, das war ja noch kurz, es hat alle genervt und die Tour hat viel zu lange gedauert, alle waren gestresst und die Verkostung hat fast nicht mehr ganz reingepasst, was natürlich alle waren gestresst und nervt. Okay, Lektion stellt keine Fragen. Meine Frage wäre, warum schmeckt Wein eigentlich so unglaublich gut aus einem Eimer durch den Strohhalm? Also was ist es an dieser Kombination, die einen einfach so voll Wonne hinterlässt? Und dann würde der, weil die lieben das ja auch. Also der Typ hat das ja geliebt. Ja, ja. Den hätte man in die Weissglut treiben können mit solchen Fragen. Weil das ist ja sein Leben. Mein Lieblingswein ist ja der aus dem Aldi, der Tetra Pak Wein ist ja für mich wirklich das Beste. Wo wird der angebaut? Ist der auch hier? Ist das ja in der Nähe? Ist der auch hier in dem Weingut? No. No, no, no, se claro, Spanier. Nein, ich finde eine ganz andere Landschaft. Das ist ja ein guter Wein. Nee, Führungen sind nichts für mich. Ich mag Shows, wo du sitzt und jemand erklärt was, der hat den Vogel und die schmeissen das rum und erzählen, der kann eine Stunde lang in der Luft bleiben oder wenn die jünger sind, können die noch länger in der Luft bleiben am Stück und so. Ich bin mir geil, so, ich gucke dazu, aber ich sitze auf einer Bank und ich kann auch mal ausschalten. Wenn die jünger, wenn was auch immer für eine Vogelart jünger ist, kann es ein bisschen länger in der Luft bleiben. Cool, aber du weißt nicht, wie der Scheiß Vogel hieß. Die haben gute Augen, die können von ganz weit oben, teilweise fliegen die über der Wolkendecke. Der Condor fliegt wahnsinnig hoch, der Condor fliegt so hoch wie Flugzeuge. Ja, 12, 13 Kilometer kommen die schon hoch, kein Problem. Und da ist es ja so fucking kalt, und dann war auch natürlich die Frage im Raum, wie können die denn bei der Kälte überleben? Und dann hieß es, naja, Vögel sind ohnehin erstmal schon mal recht heiß. Also die sind erstmal schon mal wärmer. Aber abgesehen von dem privaten Urteil, also warum können die so viel? Naja, also guck dir mal die Flügel an. Ja, ja, klar. Also guck dir mal, naja, guck dir mal diese kräftigen Schenkel. Guck dir das mal an. Und deswegen überleben die, weil die einfach richtig warm sind. Das sind wie so kleine Hotpockets in der Luft, die sind so heiß im Kern. Selbst wenn du die 20 Sekunden ins Kühlfach legst, weil du das Ding einfach nicht reinstopfen willst und die ist zu heiß, sind immer noch heiß und du verbrennst dir immer noch die Zunge. Stefan, du hast eine Nachricht bekommen, das wird doch bestimmt alle in der Klasse interessieren, was du hier so für wichtige Nachrichten bekommst, während wir uns eigentlich über Vögel unterhalten möchten. Thema
Kr-Weinhandel schreibt
Ab wann ist man Alkoholiker?
Wie viele Wein-Mails muss man
pro Tag kriegen, dass man offiziell
als Alkoholiker gilt? Ich weiß nicht, was ich da jemals
gekauft habe, I don't know, vielleicht wird der
mal irgendwas wissen. Kr-Weinhandel, vielleicht habe ich dir
mal ein paar Fragen gestellt oder so, schreibt
Loire Probierpaket Lieber Kr-Weinhandel Liebe Kr-Weinhandel-Kunden, wie Sie wissen, KR Weinhandel, vielleicht habe ich dir mal ein paar Fragen gestellt oder so, schreibt Loire Probierpaket, lieber KR Weinhandel, liebe KR Weinhandel Kunden, wie Sie wissen, sind wir stets auf der Suche nach neuen, talentierten und spannenden Produzenten, deren Weine uns faszinieren. Auf dieser Suche sind wir dieses Mal an der Loire fündig geworden. Ich dachte schon bei Ihnen fündig geworden. Also dem Teil des Anjou, Anjou, der durch seine schieferhaltigen Böden, guck mal, ich leite mal nochöden geprägt ist. Felix Sela hat das elterliche Weingut Domaine de Gaubourg übernommen, nachdem er zuvor einige Jahre eine der besternten Küchen des Hotel Le Bristol in Paris gearbeitet hat. Das kennt man doch sogar, da weiss man eine Menge drüber. Das könnt ihr kaufen, 100% Schienen Blanc, 222. Du musst nicht die Werbung einfach weiterreichen, was du da kriegst. Eins, zwei, drei, vier, fünf, sechs Flaschen kriegst du für 115 Euro inklusive Versand in Deutschland statt 138. Muss man auch mal sagen, ich glaube, kein Podcast ehrt die Spam-Mail so sehr wie wir. Wir sind die einzigen, die diese Spam-Nachrichten lesen und vorlesen. Wir wollen diese eklige Lehrerhaftigkeit hier. Niemand liest das sonst. Und ich glaube, irgendein Autor da draußen freut sich jetzt. Irgendein KI hat jetzt gerade einen Smiley auf den Lippen, wenn sie weiß, okay, dass die Nachricht hier bei uns vorgelesen wurde. Und am Ende kippt er sich dann doch einfach nur sein Billigwasser rein. Da will dann schon die Geschmacksknospen werden und einfach schon mal schön weggeknuspert. Hast du gerade den Newsletter des KR-Weinhandels? Als Spam? Ja. Als räudiger Spam-Scheisse? Ja, als räudiger Spam einfach. Noch nie hat jemand so wütend getrunken. Nur ganz kurz, wenn ich wütend bin, brauche ich nur ganz wenig Flüssigkeit. Hört ihr das da draußen, dass ich wütend trinke? Ja, ja, man kann das hören. Ist das die Wetten, das Wette? Stefan Tietze aus Kamen wettet, dass er am Trinkgeräusch die Emotionen des Trinkers erkennen kann. Wie lange muss ich in Köln wohnen? Herr Gottschalk, Herr Gottschalk, wie lange muss ich in Köln wohnen, bis Sie sagen ... Können Sie die Brille noch mal absetzen, wenn Sie mit mir reden wollen? Wenn Sie mit mir reden wollen, dann setzen Sie bitte die Brille ab. Sie brauchen nicht schreien, ich habe nur eine Brille auf und ich kann noch Kopfhörer auf.
So, dann setzen Sie jetzt die Brille ab, wenn Sie mit mir reden wollen.
Wenn Sie mit mir reden wollen, habe ich gar keine Lust, damit Sie zu reden.
Ich rede hier nicht in irgend so einem mit Wassertröpfchen auf der Brille drauf.
Jetzt habe ich keine Lust mehr auf diese Wette.
Wie, das geht nicht.
Bin ich in der Stimmung.
Das geht nicht, Tom Hanks hat bereits auf Sie gesetzt.
Wollen Sie, dass Tom Hanks weint?
Tom Hanks, was hat Tom Hanks dazu?
Was hat Tom Hanks dazu, zu diesem Streit? Well, listen, I don't know where I am, to be honest. Also, ich weiss nicht genau, wo ich bin, um ehrlich zu sein. It is very confusing for me. I've eaten so, so many gummy bears. My stomach hurts, and I don't know how long I have to endure this hell. Somebody told me that this guy is wearing glasses, and's listening to drinking water I don't understand, and this guy is constantly touching me, my knee is constantly rubbing my knee and it's getting so uncomfortable and I heard that this is just an online thing, it's not even on television. I wanna Ich möchte einfach nur gehen, weil ich sei ein bisschen nach Hause gehen, in mein Bett und verstecken. Und ich will nie wieder aus dem Bett heraus. Ich will weinen, bis ich das Bett nass ist. Und ich denke, dass ich schwimme. Also, glauben Sie, dass ich diese Wette kann oder nicht? Ich trinke mal und du machst die Augen zu und sagst mir, welche Emotionen ich habe, okay?
Stefan Tizios kam.
Man kann ja, Köln, man kann ja die Temperatur hören.
Das ist ja das Spannende bei Wasser, also die Emotionen, weil man kann ja die Temperatur hören.
Heisses Wasser klingt für den Menschen anders.
Wenn du es trinkst.
Okay, Achtung, du musst die Emotionen raten. Ja. Ja, also ausgelassen fröhlich, würde ich sagen. Nein, das ist leider falsch. Nee, dann hast du falsch gespielt, weil du hast danach dieses ... Nee, du kannst nicht sagen, dann hast du falsch gespielt, wenn es deine Aufgabe ist. Ja, als ob du jetzt in der Emotion drin warst. Wie? Ich war in der Emotion drin, also ich bin ein sehr begabter Schauspieler, der sich die Sekundenschnelle in die Emotionen bringen kann. Aber der Schauspieler, die wütend spielen, sind ja nicht zwangsläufig wütend. Ja, okay, na gut. Aber also du sagst aus, dass es traurig ist. Nee, weil du hast das gemacht. Das macht niemanden, der wütend ist oder traurig ist. Ja, war ich auch nicht, war weder wütend noch traurig. Es gibt drei Emotionen, die mir einfallen.
Nein, es gibt sieben Emotionen. Es gibt so viele Emotionen wie Tartens.
Wie Inside-Out-Characters.
Ja. Nee, ähm, meine Emotion war...
Neid.
Äh, verwirr... Verwirrung. Ich war verwirrt.
Okay, ich mach eine. Augen zu.
Okay.
Oh, das war Reue.
Eifersucht. In diesem Sinne, ähm, Null von zehn, null von zehn hat er geschafft, Herr Stephan. Schade. Tom Hanks ist in Gang. Tom Hanks muss jetzt in einen riesigen überdimensionalen Toaster steigen. Tom Hanks hält wie ein Kind die Hände vor das Gesicht und glaubt, dass er nicht mehr zu sehen ist. Trottel. Ach ja. Ich liebe Tom Hanks. Ich liebe auch Tom Hanks. Vor allem, der unterschreibt seine E-Mails mit T-Hanks, was Thanks heisst. Und allein da sage ich, geil, ist nicht sein Talent, dass man davon ablesen kann, aber es ist einfach toll.
Ich mag sowas, ich finde das richtig klasse. Und er hat tolle Figuren gespielt, dieser Atlas Express, dieser Atlantik, Antarktis Express. Cloud Atlas. Nee, der mit dem, der animierte Film. Der Polar Express, genau. Polar Express schaue ich mir jedes Jahr zu Weihnachten an.
Toller Film.
Immer wieder eine Freude.
Super Film.
Die Animationen sind klasse, es ist wirklich wie als Wanderer.
Ich habe nichts auszusetzen, ja.
Die, die man sehen kann. Und die Geschichte ist so packend und die Szene, wo diese ganzen kleinen Zwerge da laufen, ist so toll. Ja, da gibt es nichts auszusetzen, also es ist nicht in keinster Weise verstörend oder weird. Nee, ich hatte nie Albträume, nachdem ich das Film gesehen habe. Alle Songs sind ein Banger? Alle Songs sind ein Banger. Choo, choo, choo, wir reissen jetzt die Schneedecke ein. Ist für mich ein klasse Song, den ich immer singe, wenn ein Zug durch Schnee fährt, immer schön. Der ICE gräbt sich durchs Eis. Tick, tack, tick, tack, das Bordbristro macht gleich zu. Also wenn sie noch was wollen, dann kommen sie schnell rum. Psch, psch, psch, halt die Klappe im Ruheabteil ist auch eines meiner absoluten Lieblingssongs, auch wenn ich den Rap-Teil nicht so gern mag, der ist mir ein bisschen zu schnell gerappt, irgendwie, keine Ahnung warum, aber der hat irgendwie so ganz schnell, das finde ich immer nicht so gut. Neulich hat er wieder ein neues Problem gehabt beim Zugfahren. Es geht jetzt auch so, dass man inzwischen, wenn man ein Flex-Ticket hat, anders, wenn man kein Flex-Ticket hat, kann man keinen Sitzplätze mehr buchen, generell nicht. Doch, das geht. Das ist mein Problem. Mehrmals ist es schon gewesen. Und dann habe ich ein Flex-Ticket gebucht und dann bin ich morgens hin zum Bahnsteig und bin immer ein bisschen früher da. Ich bin ein Mensch, ich bin generell immer überpünktlich, weil ich denke, ich will auch noch reagieren können. Lieber zu früh als zu spät, sage ich immer. Super, super, ganz toll. Auch so noch nie gehört. Da hast du es richtig auf den Punkt gebracht. Und dann bin ich also zu früh da und plötzlich ist nebenan ein Zug, der auch in die Richtung will, was war es, Berlin oder Hamburg, irgendwas, genau auch dahin fährt.
Und ich gucke in meine Bahn-App, den hätte ich ja genommen, gerne, weil ich wollte lieber zu früh oder zu spät da sein.
Und den gab es nicht, den gab es in der Bahn-App nicht, diesen Zug. Das war einfach so ein Zug non grata.
Das ist der Polarexpress, das ist der Geisterzug, das ist der Polarexpress, der fährt bis zum Weihnachtsmann.
Ja?
Du hättest denn, Stefan, wärst du da reingegangen, hättest du den Weihnachtsmann besuchen können.
Dann wärst du ausgestiegen mit Elfen am Abend.
Der Weihnachtsmann ist in Berlin-Ostbahnhof?
Ja. Der wohnt ja in seiner Schneekuppel. Hättest du ihn direkt besuchen können.
Dann hättest du aber schon erfahren, was du zu Weihnachten kriegst.
Stefan, die aus Kamen wettet, Köln, dass man am Atmen das Geräusch erkennt. Ja? Die Emotionen am Atmen? Ja. Aber du hast vorhin gesagt, du kannst die Temperatur erkennen am Trinken. Nein, die Temperatur von Wasser hören beim Einschenken in ein Glas. Wow. Okay, das kann man ja wirklich, also wirklich? Das kann man wirklich, das ist auch jetzt kein Spaß. Also nicht die genaue, aber du hörst. So viel Spaß habe ich gerade nicht. Also das ist nicht so, dass ich sage. Das ist generell ein Problem und da habe ich auch schon ein paar Mal gesagt, das ist vielleicht mal Therapie. Aber generell, also es gibt ja Gläser und es gibt ja heißes Wasser, wenn es ein heißes Wasser vorsieht. Die Komponenten sind mir bekannt, ja.en sind mir bekannt, ja. Ich weiß nicht, wo ich anfangen soll, weil du diese Basic
nicht verstehst. Das habe ich schon verstanden, ja, ja.
Stell dir mal eine heiße Kanne Wasser vor
und dann stell dir das Geräusch vor, was dieses
heiße Wasser macht, was du so reinmachst.
Das ist etwas Sonores, was Tiefes,
was Beruhigendes, so heißer
Tee, den du so aufgiest.
Und jetzt stell dir das vor,
du nimmst so eine Karaffe mit so eiskaltem
Wasser und das gibst du ein. Das ist doch viel kristallklarer, viel höher, viel frischer klingt das, das andere klingt so sonor, tief, bassig, wummernd, wabernd, mächtig, weich, das andere hart, kalt, das klingt schon so richtig kalt. Und meinst du, dieser Effekt funktioniert auch durch eine Aufnahme? Also angenommen, ich würde verschiedene geschüttete Wässer aufnehmen. Okay, dann bereite ich das mal vor für nächste Woche. Werde ich wahrscheinlich nicht machen. Sofort vergessen. Aber dann mache ich mal eine Aufnahme mit Gradzahlen. Und dann kannst du ja mal gucken, wie nah du am Grad bist. Hast du denn auch ein Verständnis von Temperatur? Ich hab ein Verständnis von Temperatur.
Also könntest du sagen, 60, 70 Grad, 80, 20 Grad?
Ja, ja, ich glaub, alle Zwischentünde wären falsch, aber generell können wir das machen.
Okay, ja, find ich gut.
Hot Water, Eingiessen, Purpur.
Ja, nee, das darfst du jetzt aber nicht üben.
Nö, ich wollte zeigen, man muss immer alles vorbereiten.
Hot Water, Pur Cup, sound effect, here we go.
Das war jetzt wirklich heiss?
Ja, das kocht ja noch, jetzt hört man so gerne, dass es noch kocht.
Ich höre gar nichts, meine Sinne sind wirklich betäubt.
Hier, hot and water.
Das ist einfach Lava.
Also, Achtung.
Achtung, er macht's jetzt.
Was ist das für ein Wasser, was er jetzt macht?
Was ist warm?
Ja. First. Old water second. Das ist ja offensichtlich kalt. Er hat sich versprochen, er hat beides mal hot water, glaube ich, gesagt. Das hilft nicht bei dem Video. Aber die Leute sind sich einig. Hot water pouring is one of the most soothing sounds in existence, in my opinion.
It did sound a little different to me.
Are you still alive?
Ist ein anderer Kommentar. Finde ich aber eine gute Frage.
Bei so einem YouTube-Video, du weisst nie, ob die Leute, die du da siehst, noch leben.
Ah, okay. Er hat kommentiert.
Yes, sorry, don't make many videos anymore. Jesus. Aber gut, aber ich glaube, er hat das so ein bisschen als passiv-aggressive Wo kommen die neuen Videos endlich? Ich glaube, genau so war es auch gemeint. Aber ich glaube, er war das eher als, ich glaube, es war so gemeint als, geht's dir gut, alles in Ordnung, wir machen uns Sorgen. Er macht ein Testvideo mit heißem Wasser im Cup und kaltes Wasser im Cup. Was soll dabei passieren? Ich fand ihn sympathisch und ich hab mir irgendwie Sorgen gemacht, weil er sah auch irgendwie schon angeschlagen aus. Und dann mach ich mir einfach Sorgen, ob er noch lebt. Aber er macht doch spannende Experimente, warum Sorgen? Naja, wenn du so ein Video nach fünf Jahren siehst, weißt du nicht, ob die Person noch lebt. Da kann alles passiert sein. Mit der Person kann alles passieren. Die kann Körperteile verloren haben, die kann diverse Erlebnisse
haben, die kann ein komplett anderer Mensch sein.
Also nur weil du atmest, heisst das ja
nicht, dass dieselbe Person noch existiert,
es kann ja eine andere Person sein. Da finde ich es schon mal
gut, dass man einfach nachfragt, bist du noch am Leben?
Es ist schön, wenn sich jemand fragt,
ob du noch lebst. Ich finde das schön.
Ich finde das eine merkwürdige Suggestivfrage.
Also alles daran sagt, ah, wir machen uns Sorgen, weil du siehst so aus, ob du dich umbr. Ich finde das schön. Ich finde das eine merkwürdige Suggestivfrage. Also alles daran sagt,
ah, wir machen uns Sorgen, weil du siehst so aus,
ob du dich umbringst.
Ja, das stimmt. Solche Kommentare kriege ich auch
manchmal so. Also nicht mit
Umringen, aber von wegen,
irgendwie ist alles in Ordnung, du siehst so müde aus
oder so, das ist schon ein bisschen unangenehm.
Aber
ja, was willst du darauf sagen?
Ja, was willst du darauf sagen? Super unangenehm. Nicht immer die Äusserlichkeiten kommentieren, generell, generell, generell. Äusserlichkeiten kommentieren, lass das einfach. Das muss nicht sein. Kommentiert die inneren Werte. Kommen wir also jetzt zu E. Oh, wir haben es schon weit geschafft, offensichtlich. Wir sind bei E. Energiewende. Ja. Geht es da endlich voran? Drehen sich endlich die Windkraftwerke, oder was ist los? Florentin, wie sieht es bei dir aus? Hast du schon eine Wärmepumpe? Ich habe noch keine Wärmepumpe, ich habe aber Heizung, benutze ich kaum noch, ich habe ganz, ganz dicke Pullis, die ich anziehen will. Dicke Socken, dicke Handschuhe. Ich habe tatsächlich eine Technik entwickelt, und zwar, ich bin ja bekannt für meine breiten Bettdecken. Also da bin ich ja, das kennen die Leute von mir, das wissen die Leute von mir, das lieben die Leute an mir. Dafür, dass wir beide Geschichten fünf, sechs, sieben bis acht Mal erzählen, nein, ich wusste nicht, dass du ein Mensch breiter Bettdecken bist. Doch, doch, ich bin ein Mensch breiter Bettdecken, ich liebe es richtig groß und lappig. Ich bin gerade bei zwei Meter vierzig. Breit, breit, breit, breit, breit, so breit es geht. Noch breiter als lang. Wirklich so breit, wie es geht. Ja, meine ist zwei vierzig mal zwei,20. Fantastisch. Aber dafür dünn. Ganz dünn! Ich finde, eine Bettdicke sollte sein wie ein Strudel, wie ein Apfelstrudel. Dünne Schichten, aber ganz viele. Und jetzt allerdings, ich hatte sonst immer zwei Einser-Matratzen nebeneinander als Doppelbett und jetzt ist mir aber eine abhanden gekommen. Eine Matratze ist jetzt weg. Warum, wo ist die abhanden gekommen? Wie geht so eine Matratze abhanden? Naja, du weißt ja, wie es ist. Man guckt da manchmal nicht hin, man lagert da Sachen drauf, dann ist der Laptop drauf, dann räumt man ein bisschen was um, dann stellt man den Schrank um und so und plötzlich merkt man, hä, Moment mal, wo ist jetzt die Matratze hin? Und jetzt ist die Matratze weg. So, und jetzt habe ich sozusagen nur noch ein halbes Bett. Also ich habe schon noch Lattenrost für beide. Noch eine Rückfrage, weil die ist ja nicht so einfach weg. Also die verlegt man ja nicht, man macht ja nichts mit der Matratze. Die wird irgendwo sein, aber ich habe jetzt aktuell, weiß ich jetzt gar nicht. So eine Matratze ist ja gross. Also ist so ein sehr großes Haus, wo die dann mal verloren gehen kann. Nee, gar nicht, überhaupt nicht. Ich musste auch umschichten. Kann auch sein, dass die übereinander liegen oder so. Ich habe es nicht nachgeguckt. Sir, die Matratze ist im Westflügel abhanden gekommen. Och Gott, wie kommt die denn dahin, der kleine Racker? Oder im Irrgarten. Dann hol sie doch. Moment mal, sie versucht zu fliehen. Zum Glück haben wir den Irrgarten installiert. Die Matratze ist im Irrgarten. Irgendwo im Irrgarten. Ist das eigentlich ein Klischee? Nein, ich glaube nicht. Dieses Irrgartenphänomen oder gab es das wirklich?
Nein, das hat man gemacht, um da miteinander zu schlafen.
Und die Leute das nicht mitkriegen.
Was?
Du musst es ja bei so einer höfischen
Bei so einer höfischen Gesellschaft,
da ist es natürlich irgendwie,
man ist unverheiratet, es gibt keine
Verhütung und nicht alles, es ist alles skandalös.
Aber da reicht ja ein Riesenhaus.
Lass uns mal zusammen ins Labyrinth gehen und dann verirrt man da. Und dann kommt man nicht raus, dann muss man da übernachten. Dann muss man da miteinander schlafen. Und dann muss man da, um warm zu bleiben, dann den Akt vollziehen. Ich glaube, du nügst mir ins Gesicht. Also so habe ich das verstanden. Ich dachte, das wäre ein reiner Lustgarten. Das wäre eine absolut schlüpfrige Angelegenheit, diese Labyrinthe. Einerseits natürlich erst mal Angeberei mit Gartenkunst, dass man sich die Gärtner leisten kann, um das so in Schuss zu halten, das ist ja auch nicht billig, also Gärtner kosten ja auch gutes Geld. Das ist eher eine Gartenkunst, ein Gartenkunstgrund. Ja, absolut, das auch, aber warum dann so hoch? Du siehst ja dann nicht gar nicht, was los ist. Stell dir vor, das Labyrinth ist nur halb so hoch, dann könnte man das auch bestaunen von außen. Und so ist es schwieriger. Deswegen glaube ich, das hat schon durchaus schlüpfrige Gründe, dass du dich da zurückziehen kannst und da man sagt ja auch, in die Büsche gehen. Also sagt man ja auch. Ja, ja, ja. Also hier laut modernster KI-Technologie ist es Punkt eins, Ästhetik und Prestige, ein Labyrinth kann den Eindruck von Reichtum, Raffinesse und Macht verstärken. Also vielleicht, das ist ja genau, was du erreichen willst. Du hast mich noch nicht gefragt, Stefan, wie kann ich meinen Reichtum, Raffinesse und Macht Eindruck verstärken? Und du hast mir das Labyrinth empfohlen, ja. Genau, unter anderem Unterhaltung und Freizeit. In vergangenen Jahrhunderten waren Labyrinter ein beliebter Zeitvertreib für die Aristokratie.
Ich hätte neulich einen Gedanken gehabt übrigens, Zeitvertreib ist ja merkwürdig, weil man sagt die ganze Zeit, man hat zu wenig Zeit und ah, das Leben ist zu kurz und so, ne, Carpe Diem mässig und dann ist aber Zeitvertreib tatsächlich ein grosser Bestandteil menschlichen Lebens. Da habe ich mir vorgestellt, ein Mensch, der unendlich lange lebt.
Also die Zeit ist quasi keine Währung mehr. Wäre Zeitvertreib dann noch, dann wäre Zeitvertreib, finde ich, keine Sache mehr, die du machen würdest. Oder würdest du nicht nur noch Zeitvertreib machen, weil du hast viel mehr Zeit, die du vertreiben musst? Die Zeit, die geht dich ja an. Du sagst, weg damit, weg mit der Zeit. Aber dann habe ich irgendwie so einen komischen Gedankenimpuls gehabt, so ein Gefühl, wenn ich unendlich viel Zeit habe, dann mache ich doch sinnvollere. Naja, aber sagen wir mal so, selbst wenn du unendlich lange lebst, du willst ja ins Bett. Du schläfst die Nacht durch, dann wachst du auf, dann lebst du so bis 14 Uhr und dann eigentlich willst du ab 14 Uhr schon wieder ins Bett. Und die Zeit bis dahin muss halt vertrieben werden, damit du dich wieder in ein kuscheliges Bett legen kannst. Das heißt, da musst du einfach was vertreiben. Ich verstehe, auf der Ratsunternehmung verstehe ich das alles. Ich glaube nur im Kopf, mein erster Impuls war, nee, dann würde ich glaube ich nicht bei TikTok abhängen. Was seltsam ist, weil man hat wenig Zeit und dann bringt man das so um. Ja. eigentlich, wenn man dann unendlich viel Zeit hat, dann hat man doch, kann man ja die grossen Dinge machen. Wie zum Beispiel? Was würdest du dann machen? So ein Riesenhaus bauen. Okay, also du würdest wirklich zum Obi fahren, erst mal Schrauben, Bretter, Mörtel und dann einfach rühren. Wenn du unendlich viel Zeit hast, hast du ja auch gleich unendlich viel Geld, weil du ja unendlich viel arbeiten kannst, um unendlich viel zu sparen. Sagen wir, wenn die Zeit keine Knappheit mehr ist, kannst du ja so viel, das ist ja selbst ein geringverdienender Job, ist ja am Ende ausreichend. Du machst dann extra Schichten im Callcenter, um dann für die nächsten hunderttausend Jahre noch genug Geld zu haben, um deine Pyramide zu bauen. Also nach tausend Jahren hat jeder ein gewisses Kapital erwirtschaftet, wenn man unendlich lange leben kann, und dann kann ich ja mein Haus bauen. Vielleicht nicht, weil dann wieder alles teuer ist, weil wenn ich lange lebe, leben ja alle anderen auch lange. Ach, okay, das auch, okay. Sind wir noch in einem RAF-Ding, oder ist das jetzt ein Teil davon? Nee, das war letzte Woche. Ich wollte nur sagen, mir ist, wie gesagt, eine Matratze abhanden gekommen. Das heißt, meine Matratze ist jetzt schmaler als davor. Heißt, meine Bettdecke ist eigentlich noch breiter als davor im Verhältnis. Und was jetzt passiert ist, ich liege in der Mitte und die Bettdecke umwölbt mich komplett und geht an den Seiten runter, bis zum Boden. Und das hat mich so eingesiegelt. Das sieht aus, als ob du schwebst. Ja, wenn man reinkommt, ist das auch wie so ein Zaubertrick. Du siehst nur die Füsse und die Bettdecke drüber und denkst dir, wow, wow, wow, was ist hier los? Weil du immer so offen schläfst und die beiden Hände so nach hinten. Ja, jetzt nach oben ... Mindfreak-mäßig. Ja, und dann läuft immer noch Camina Burana laut, weil du es zum Einschlafen brauchst, wie andere Wahlgesänge. Ja. Und dann kommt man in sein Zimmer und dann ... Und Florentin schwebt mit einem offenen Mund, offenen Augen. Mit den Armschienen natürlich, schön die Armschienen auch noch an der Seite. Und das ist eine gute Show. Aber da muss ich sagen, es wird unfassbar heiß, es ist unglaublich, es ist ein riesen Temperaturunterschied, ob deine Bettdecke wirklich nach außen komplett versiegelt und ich habe jetzt gemerkt, ich brauche nur noch eine dünne Bettdecke, weil ich wirklich so eingeschweißt bin, also wirklich so hauteng, eingeschweißt, bin ich da drin, Armschienen, Halskrause, Zahnspange. Ja, alles fixiert. Alles fixiert.
Ich fühle mich wirklich wie so eine Actionfigur,
die ja auch mit diesen Plastikbändern überall fixiert ist in der Packung
und dann nochmal eingeschweißt.
Wie Frankenstein, das ist super warm,
es ist richtig gut. Also falls euch kalt ist,
enger, enger, enger, enger, enger.
Es muss alles ganz eng um euch herum sein.
Wir wollen ja unsere Häuser warm haben im Winter
und wir wollen aber jetzt nicht irgendwie mehr Heizkosten haben oder generell Energie verschwenden. Also eine grosse Decke übers Haus legen. Die auf beiden Seiten, das ist wichtig, auf den Boden geht, empirisch überlegt. Aber die muss wirklich riesig sein, die Decke. Ich rede jetzt nicht von vielen Decken, von denen man wie so ein Lager drumherum hat. Nein, wie gesagt, eine grosse, dünne Decke. Eine riesige Decke. Dünn, ruhig. Ja, dünn. Aber, oh, an der würde ich gerne schlafen. Stell dir mal vor, du hast eine Decke. Auf der anderen Seite, irgendwann wird es ja gefährlich. Also irgendwann ist ja eine Decke zu groß, sodass du dich darin verlierst. Weil dann kannst du aufwachen und weißt nicht, wo du bist. Was mich so nervt, wo es keine Lösung für gibt, ist, mein Inlet verrutscht die ganze Zeit. Ja. Und dann, das verschiebt sich innen drin. Und dann hast du außen, gerade bei so grossen Decken, manchmal so wirklich, so zentimeterweise nichts drin. Das ist das erbärmlichste Gefühl. Und es hängt so über. Das ist diese, diese, manchmal fühle ich mich auch so, wie so ein leerer Bettbezug, wo nichts drin ist. So nehme ich dich auch wahr. Und du denkst dir so, da ist nichts dahinter. So, das ist so, ja, das sieht schön aus und Snoopy lächelt mich an vom Bettbezug, alles wunderbar, aber da ist einfach keine Substanz dahinter. Die Substanz ist alle hinten runtergerutscht, die hängt alle irgendwo hinten drin, aber ich will dann auch nicht die Decke rumfummeln. Und das ist wirklich so ein ganz trauriger Anblick, so ein schlapper Snoopy, der da einfach so da liegt und nichts drin hat. Da bräuchte man, aber kann man da nicht so Knöpfe machen, wo man das irgendwie fixiert hat? Ich habe mich natürlich recherchiert, weil es ist wirklich eines meiner grössten Probleme. Top drei Probleme meines Lebens. Und deswegen habe ich da jetzt sehr viel recherchiert, sehr viel Arbeit reingesteckt und überlegt, was kann man da machen. Und dann gibt es durchaus so große Knöpfe, die man so durchsteckt, aber dann hast du so Riesenknöpfe, die dich dann nachts berühren könntest.
Und du willst ja, das ist ja nicht, was du willst, das wäre noch ein grösseres Problem als alle Probleme, die ich jetzt gerade habe.
Also es gibt ja diese rostigen Stahlklemmen, die kannst du halt wirklich links und rechts da wirklich so rein montieren.
Die man von Filmsets kennt, von so Riesenkabeln.
Genau, da ist so eine Hydraulikpresse, mit der kannst du das wirklich fixieren und dann rutscht da gar nichts mehr.
Meine Idee war nähen.
Also das so draußen an die Ecken, die Ecken vernähen. Ja, aber dann kannst du es ja nicht mehr abziehen.
Fuck it.
Du wärst bereit ...
Nein, nein, nein, dann wieder abreissen halt.
Abreissen?
Schere durch.
Wie oft wechselst du deine Bettdecke, also deine Bettwäsche?
Muss ich sagen, zu selten, durchaus zu selten.
Nicht so selten wie ich, aber ja gut.
Aber trotzdem ...
Du nähst es ein und reisst es dann ab. Naja, man kann doch mit der Schere dann einmal durchgehen. Und dann vernäht es wieder neu. Wow. Wie lange kann denn Nähen dauern? Das ist Commitment. Ich hab mein Leben noch nicht genäht, aber vielleicht passt das. Das ist Commitment. Das ist wirklich Commitment. Ja, wenn du so reagierst, ist es wahrscheinlich nicht die richtige Lösung, weil deine Reaktion sagt, das ist sau viel Arbeit. Aber man braucht ja nur so zwei so Piekser. Es ist ja nicht eine Gewalt, die das auseinanderreißt, es ist nur die Zeit. Aber ja, das ist die Frage, das ist die Frage, welche Kräfte wirken da eigentlich. Welche Gehkräfte wirken auf die Ecken einer Decke? Wahrscheinlich hättest du dann wirklich eine Überraschung, dass das am Morgen komplett verrissen ist und all die Nahten, die da rausgerissen sind, so richtig gewalttätig, so wirklich offen und du denkst dir, was wirkt da eigentlich? Der Menschheit-Lösung dafür sind harte Plastikklemmen oder so dicke Nadeln, die man durchsticht, so Knöpfe. Genau. Was stimmt mit uns nicht als Menschheit? Also erstens, das ist Punkt eins, weil, wer will denn so harte Dinge plötzlich in der Nacht berühren? Ja. Im Bett, furchtbar. Und Punkt zwei ist, warum haben das Hotelbetten nicht das Problem? Gut, weil die jeden Tag neu bezogen werden oder aufgeschüttelt werden. Ich überlege nur gerade, weil du könntest ja das eigentlich, das wirklich schwer machen. Weil wenn du jetzt wirklich diese Decke hast, wie ich, die an den Seiten des Bettes runterhängt, Wenn du da jetzt noch Gewichte dranhängst, die du wirklich mit so harten Metallklemmen, vielleicht so wirklich so Marmorkugeln, so Stahlklunker, die da einfach dranhängen, dann kannst du ja Unglaubliches schaffen. Da wirst du ja wirklich so festgezogen, da oben. Also es gibt ja auch Druckdecken, wo du wirklich da richtig viel Blei und Asbest da drin hast in so einer Bettdecke, dass sich das wirklich nach unten drückt, damit du anscheinend besser schlafen kannst.
Ich habe da Erfahrungsberichte gelesen, die absolut schrecklich sind, von Menschen, die sich nicht mehr bewegen konnten und den Rest ihres Lebens da verendet wurden.
Die wollen aufstehen.
Die immer noch schlafen müssen, jeden Tag. Und ganz, ganz schrecklich.
Ganz, ganz schrecklich.
Also du kannst gar nicht aufstehen und sagst, ich muss jetzt hier schlafen.
Meine Definition von Paradies ist, jemand sagt mir, du musst jetzt die ganze Zeit schlafen. Ja. Du musst die ganze Zeit im Bett machen. Aber wirklich auch als Kind, du hast ja schon als Kind viel geschlafen und jetzt auch, du bist einfach ein Schläfer. Ich liebe Schlafen, ich bin gut im Schlafen. Du bist eigentlich mehr ein Bär, eigentlich bist du so der Titzbär. Der Hund eigentlich, also eigentlich bräuchte ich das 16 Stunden. Ja, aber Hundedösen glaube ich immer nur so. Das ist nicht so wirklich so ein richtiger Tiefschlaf. Doch, Hundedösen. Ich glaube, so ein Bär oder so ein kleines Eichwärm, die so richtig... Ich schlafe richtig tief. Ja. Ja, wir haben es geschafft bis eh. Wir sind tatsächlich nicht komplett durch die Woche gekommen. Wie Feierend. Ja, Feierabend, wir sind nicht komplett durch die Woche gekommen. Wir werden natürlich nächste Woche weitermachen. Ja, wir haben gekündigt. Wir haben gesagt, das ist, genau, wir haben gekündigt, wir werden nicht weitkommen, es ist zu viel passiert. Wir sind bis elf gekommen, natürlich machen wir nächste Woche. Ihr kennt uns doch. Ja, absolut. Wenn wir was ankündigen. Dann ziehen wir es auch durch. Wir haben es leider nicht geschafft, alle News der Woche komplett durchzuackern. Es ist leider einfach
wahnsinnig viel passiert. Ihr schickt uns ja auch immer
Newsstreifen ein, ausgeschnitten
aus der Zeitung und alles. Vielen, vielen Dank.
Wie gesagt, wir sind
kein News-Podcast. Jetzt haben wir mal gesagt, dass wir das
für diese Woche mal zusammenfassen. Haben es nur bis E
geschafft. F gibt's dann nächste
Woche. F, G und dann
H und I.
Was haben wir dann? Und J, K und A, B, C, F, G und dann H und I und J K A, B, C, D, E, F, G H, I, J, K, L, M, N, O, P Q, R, S, T, U, V Now I know my ABCs Du kannst jederzeit abbrechen.
Ich weiss nicht, wie es weitergeht,
dass das Podcast UFO schwebt.
Und wir schweben ab, macht's gut, bis zum nächsten Mal.
Tschüss, habt eine schöne Woche, macht nicht so viele News, bitte, tschüss.